pasar a la asada culminado su vuelta a
la escena diplomática regional
asistiendo como dirigente de la
República árabe Siria tras más de una
década de aislamiento internacional la
participación de alassad en esta cumbre
de la liga árabe que se Está celebrando
en el balneario de lleda es meramente
representativo Pero quiere dar un
mensaje
contundente de unidad árabe ante los
desafíos regionales las consecuencias
económicas de la Guerra de Ucrania
afectan a todos los países de la región
al igual que la crisis de los refugiados
sirios y ahora también la crisis
humanitaria en Sudán tras el estallido
del conflicto la normalización de las
relaciones de los Países Árabes y Siria
también trae compromisos por parte de la
SAT Siria se ha convertido en un
arcoestado por las sanciones
internacionales y la guerra en curso el
contrabando de la droga conocida como
captagon fuera de las fronteras sirias
intranquiliza a sus vecinos como
Jordania Irak y Arabia saudí también
se está buscando
una solución política al conflicto
Después de 12 años de cruenta guerra
civil para que se puedan dar las
condiciones del retorno de más de 7
millones de desplazados repartidos por
toda la región
asad ha regresado al redil de la liga
árabe pasando por alto los crímenes y
los abusos durante la Guerra
un duro golpe para los millones de
refugiados sirios los Víctimas de la
guerra y los miles de desaparecidos en
las cárceles sirias